you know animation rules the roost here
at Comic Con and so there are so many
great animated films and different comic
books and everything you can see Taran I
want to ask you about this how good does
it feel to do something where you don't
have to get dressed up I I really love
voice work I always have done and um and
as you say you know there are there can
be lots of opportunities to be involved
in animation as an actor but something
like this a kind of quite classic Henson
product in that it's all done with
puppets those opportunities don't really
come along very often so now for me that
in itself would have been exciting
enough I'm also just a massive fan of
the Dark Crystal that the 1982 film and
and it's a great great honor to be part
of this new chapter this prequel and it
is part of the Henson family legacy and
I mean when you talk about Jim Henson is
a man who shaped people's lives and
changed America and they say your father
was just great what he was great but how
this is a prequel so it's different than
the original but explain it is different
but it's very similar you know Netflix
gave us this huge opportunity to make a
series that looks like the movie so they
said like use puppets make it look as
rich on authentic as the original film
and we were just blown away with that
like that they would want to make such a
huge investment and take a great
wonderful chance on puppets because as
you said there's a lot of animation out
there and not a lot of puppetry rights
but we really went for it Louie learned
everything there is to learn about
shooting puppets and then he added
tremendously to how the puppets are shot
so it really feels modern and great and
he just had Mark Hamill moderate your
panel so what's that like being in Hall
H with Mark Hamill you didn't mana right
he was a guest but then he ended up but
our cameras today to cover anything and
we were very happy was just like like
everyone we became we were like part of
the audience just standing on stage next
day she's an amazing storyteller
obviously an incredible act a wonderful
person
Taran's you know second father now
and I'm saying earlier actually and I do
feel this the great thing about mark is
you know in terms of movies of this era
this early 80s period he really is an
icon and it just feels there's something
that just feels really appropriate about
him being involved in this series yeah I
was watching the trailer and then I
looked at her eyes the movie from 82
Jennifer Connelly was in that movie she
was just that's a different one it's
funny often actually the same breath
right and because everybody and so
Jennifer was just amazing she looks she
has something special okay explain the
prequel tie-ins can you if you can tell
us it's it really connects directly to
the film because it you're backing up in
time in the original film if people have
seen the film the gelfling go and visit
a ruin and they think there are the only
two gelfling left in the world they see
this ruin of a culture and a
civilization and they realize they came
from somewhere so in our television
series we go back to that time and that
civilization and we see the amazing it's
a very big tapestry and many many
characters is very populated colorful
you know spectacular world and so in a
way it's a little different from the
film because it films very dark and
subdued and quiet with just not that
many characters and this is a this is a
very vibrant big dramatic action-packed
adventure it's an emotional and we need
it you know obviously with the beauty of
the handsome puppets but we needed a
cast you know led by Taran but you know
a cast of that magnitude and amplitude
is just to just to bring the emotion
forward I mean we have I think we have
the best gas in the world ever put
together Cernan was the first one in and
then he kind of you know every we've
created a snowball and so many like
every role is played by somebody say
that but I think you know
there's you know it's a great great
thing to be a part of and you know Simon
Pegg and Mark Hamill a little you know
can actually manage all these people
know you know the original movie is just
so if you haven't seen the original Dark
Crystal you have to see it it's amazing
it's unlike anything else preferably
before always 30th because there's a
series coming out but you know I think
as lovely as it is of you to say that I
think it's just it really it's just a
great thing to be a part of what I asked
you a row couple rumors about Wolverine
yes
no it's a lovely that anyone I'm
surprised by it I've never really
thought of myself that way that anyone
would think that that was a possibility
there's no truth to it but it's a lovely
rumor and of course those films are
fantastic I'm a fan and it's lovely to
be mentioned we might be closing a fake
old shape which feel quite Maureen
actually button them will do you know
you see this series in it how do you
continue this legacy the Henson legacy
and all the stuff you know thank you for
asking I think that you know our main
contribution is to continue the the
tradition of puppetry and puppet
building and training and encouraging
puppeteers because you know it's it's
not as big of a thing in culture as
animation you know puppetry is still a
little bit more specialized and
puppeteers as heart you know we we talk
about our great cast wheels of amazing
cast of puppeteers you know twelve
twelve people who pretty much carried
this whole entire show on their arms you
know and you know it's I think what
we've done for puppetry is just you know
keep keep the tradition going
and you
not let people forget the techniques and
and the art form because it's it is it's
pretty special to other things when I
was about singing - yeah what can you
tell us and what are you singing I
really I'm not allowed to tell you no I
can tell you that we're working on it
now we're having a really really great
time there's a couple of new people
who've joined Who I am
staggered are involved but I can tell
you they are and I think it's going to
be great it's a really cool new chapter
the story and as someone who loves
singing it's a it's a really great job
for me
but I don't know what I do know one of
the songs I'm doing but I can't tell you
you can't tell me I'm sorry that's all
right August 6 is the blu-ray and DVD
release of Rocket Man Bites yeah it has
some special scenes that we're missing
including it's very exciting it's very
very exciting so we shot so much on that
movie and for whatever reason the pacing
economy of storytelling you know lots of
it didn't make it into the film and that
some of it we've really mourned because
there's some bits that were really proud
of but now's an opportunity to show
people and so yeah when it when it comes
out on DVD people will see some extra
content hopefully not see the movie for
the first time if you haven't seen in
the theater shame on you but it'll be
really exciting to share these extra
bits a lot of people singing that there
are almost 200 million worldwide
yeah it's been a great it's been really
quite it's been an amazing episode in my
life and I'm so pleased that people
connected with it in the way they did
yeah and it is really cool if you get to
see some of those left out things like I
was talk about Hong Ki cab we just saw
that yeah I've never seen it before
how's it spectacular yeah it's cool it's
that was a you know so at the end of the
the duet that myself and Richard Madden
do we there was a we shot a big ants
break kind of energy musical style and
it didn't make the movie but it's it's
really cool so you know that's on there
which is exciting
will it be more puppy well they were the
be more puppies in the future what we
see more we are always doing pop it's
not we do puppets for kids we have great
you know preschool puppetry we have now
puppetry is kind of popular for adults
too yeah
we do you know alternative type puppetry
programming for adults and then you know
we're working on Fraggle Rock for the
future and people want to see that come
back have you had a great comic-con
experience what's it been like it was a
yeah guys has it's been pretty great
right that's really that's creating
yesterday was really good people
responded really well
7500 people give you love at the same
time it's just it's just a tremendous
experience you know it was huge to show
episode one like that you know and and
you know nobody's really seen it and
have thousands of people see it at once
linked and they were pretty riveted they
just and by the way just soaked in
anything outside to get in there it's
not like they're they're like oh I'm
just gonna walk up and go see if they
sleep outside the thing that people
don't know any other Carothers and know
is that it's how people fan over each
other like how the you know the actor is
like they meet each other outside that
go I'm a huge fan of yours that you just
met the flash I mean for me I have this
was one of the first things I ever did
when I first came to America is
comic-con and it has a really special
place in my heart I am a comic book fan
I just think the energy is amazing the
juicer have I dressed up here
ah no only it's talent but I know I'd
love to but it just I think there's
something in the UK we don't quite have
anything compare of whether there are
comic conventions now but we don't have
like something that's got this sort of
level of unbridled joy you know I would
really we maybe take ourselves a bit too
seriously for it and I don't know I
don't know I don't know what it is but I
love it yeah I absolutely love it
you